à michel delpech bonsoir alors wait is
wight cette enquête années soixante dix
d'une chanson qui me la croissance du
terme mais elle n'a pas complètement
parce que le monde est vraiment elle
raconte un événement ponctuel mais enfin
bon elle a eu tellement de succès que
cela change aujourd'hui se fasse
ouais on se replonge dans l'époque voilà
c'est fini tu es allé à l'île de wight
jamais non on va je suis allé au
festival de bougies aux pauvres parce
que vrai quand tu fais entre deux
chansons wade a fallu quand même que
d'immenses eric woerth est vraiment
way up poursuivant dans un autre
festival 7 mbj
c'est sous la pluie c'est un échec
matériel c'était trois jours debout et
on a vendu combien 6%
tu sais pas on m'a dit un million avait
peut-être que c'était un peu plus
peut-être que c'était puissant
alors avant qu'ils aient quoi tu as été
découvert par qui gabo parce que deux
versions la chose tu as chanté à une
fête de lycée à la fin de l'année il ya
deux versions il y en a une c'est deux
pions qui t'ont vu chantiers qui sont
les serres le tour des maisons de
disques à paris et il y en a une autre
où il y avait un directeur artistique
dans la salle c'est laquelle la bonne
car dont la première version est la
bonne ouais c'est des pions compris les
des pions qui était au lycée je suis
confiant labonte oise voiliers qui m'ont
c'était le cas d'aurel mes chansons
busan a évoqué et qui m'ont qui m'ont
piloter un petit poème on est dans une 2
on dit ça bug vient de disparaître
ton premier tube c'était chez leur est
donc à l'époque de wight is wight et
séchez le raid s'est fait quoi d'autre
l'inventaire 66 ouais ouais ça a été
deux gros truc sac à main et white is
wight c'était le troisième c'est ça je
crois alors à l'époque tu étais le
prototype fans du chanteur ambitieux un
sétois même qu'il reconnaît d'ailleurs
parce que en fait la notoriété c'était
quand même ton ambition principale je
voulais être connu non mais c'était ma
motivation première est par exemple été
gêné quand on ne reconnaissait pas dans
les lieux publics
je n'ai pas génial mais j'étais furieuse
était furieux quand tu signer les
autographes et qui avait un mec qui
disait qui c'est celui là ça tombe bien
les kwassa t'énerver c'est vrai le
problème c'est qu'en 71 ça commence a
justement tête un peu le vertige de ton
succès c'est de commencer à flipper tu
dit une phrase tu dis si je commence à
être second on va dire que je pèse donc
à un moment tu as eu le vertige qu'est
ce qui s'est passé je vais déjà
commencer à avoir peur que ça marche
plus aussi bien après ces gros tubes
bah oui parce que quand on a le tube
comme comme le white is right donc on se
demande un peu ce qui va se passer c'est
ouais surtout que la chanson était dans
un style très différent de ce que
j'avais fait jusqu à voir donc je ne
savais pas quelle route il fallait
prendre
je commençais à cogiter ouais tu voulais
imposer ton style et voulait pas
seulement faire des chansons courent je
disais à l'époque c'est à dire non je
soufflais bâtir une carrière je vais
bâtir un vrai style et toi ce qu'on
voulait c'est qu'ils fassent des tubes
qui se vend resté un peu british airways
a paru sur le moment et puis beaucoup
pouvait être un vrai chanteur oui pas
une idole pour les minettes
je veux bien ça aussi ouais jouer tout à
la fois aujourd'hui tu penses quoi du
delpech de l'époque qu'il était un peu
insupportable
oui tu penses à poudre r je pense que
c'était un petit pont avant
j'aime pas vous regardez d'ailleurs
c'est quand on voit les documents ouais
ça t'énerve j'aime pas trouvée parce que
je vois tout mais les joies ce qu'il ya
dans mes yeux je jouais je pensais pas
toujours et puis il y avait les
rouflaquettes et les laisse mise à faire
jouer et regarder ça ben ça m'emmerdait
pas puisque je les avais à l'époque mais
maintenant ça va c'est ridicule d'un
être être un peu nos de quoi et je
trouve qu est ce que vous imaginez un
peu trop pour le doubs en 1977 dont
était toujours au top puisque tu as quoi
tu as si j'étais chanteur tu as le loir
et cher et ce sont des morceaux quand
même aussi énorme enfin je veux dire
qu'il n'y avait pas de faire des
compliments parce que c'est pas le genre
de la maison mais enfin quand même je
veux dire si c'est rare que je dise ça
mais c'est vrai c'était très très grands
morceaux et à son bras tu commence à
flipper qu'est ce qui se passe mais il
s'est passé que j'ai eu des
les problèmes importants ma vie
personnelle qui est mon petit peu
déséquilibré et puis ça s'est conjugué
par d'autres choses et j'ai passé un
sale quart d'heure
ouais et c'est à dire oui tu as eu un
problème on peut on peut le dire
maintenant on a eu des problèmes d'abord
amoureux avec ta avec ta femme
oui j'ai eu des problèmes comme ça et
qu'ils se sont eux qui ont été en plus
puis il ya eu là bas oui et où c'est à
dire que tu été marié qu'une comédienne
c'était un couple uni et est même un
modèle dans le show business
enfin bon on était tous les deux mois je
me soigne un truc qui m'avait choqué je
sais pas pourquoi vous l'aviez fait à
l'époque c'est que vos enfants vous
aviez posé nue dans ici paris
ouais pourquoi tel effet ça c'était le
côté chanteur fou où c'était quoi
non parce qu'on était vraiment comme ça
voilà on vivait comme ça un bref donc
les photos qu'on faisait ressembler l
avis que vous allez répondre maintenant
quand même dit ça ça me paraît insensé
ouais alors donc à ce moment là oui
effectivement ta femme de keats à 7-7
mais mal ce qu'on peut comprendre
et puis à d'autres problèmes c'est quoi
c'est son problème pc tools été lancés
dans une aventure spirituelle un petit
peu mais j'avais abordé
l'hindouisme vous dise les choses comme
ça ça ne pas très bien réussi
ça c'est ça qui me fait surtout beaucoup
plient p alors quand tu parles de cette
époque de flip qui a duré pas mal
d'années tu dis c'est une défaillance de
la volonté qui vous emporte dans la
tragédie stark à un moment tu avais
l'impression de vouloir s'accrocher à
quelque chose et que tu ne trouvait rien
tu ne se met pas de point d'appui ce
l'impression d'être dans une espèce de
der nation c'est comme ça que j'ai vécu
puisque ça partait d'un problème bon
sentimentale et spirituelle et c'est
nous tous ramenés à ce à quoi il ya peu
lorsque j'étais en dessous du niveau de
la mer j'ai l'impression d'être des
damnés comme un petit à un psychiatre ou
un psychologue ou un psychanalyste je
sais pas tu as dit à un moment est ce
que c'est vrai ça c'était la seule
chance de s'en sortir c'était la
lobotomie quand même terrible je suis
barjots parce que j'ai fait quelques
séjours données avec les plis des cure
de sommeil et tout ça et j'étais dans
une clinique de saint brieuc vraiment
moi j'avais dû abandonner une tournée
que tu en train de faire et on contrôle
est arrivé en bretagne au fait comment
cela va se passer je me suis donc
retrouvé à saint brieuc dans une
clinique il y avait un mec était qui
était le directeur de la clinique qui va
garder comme une espèce de cobayes
conférence était très excité à l'idée
d'avoir une personne connue et on va
voir peut manipuler tout ça alors
voir dans la chambre un moment donné est
venu vous savez toute façon vous pourrez
jamais vivre une vie comme les autres
c'est fini c'est fini pour vous faut
dire que j'étais très jeune très abîmé
mais il m'a dit donc je vous propose une
chose c'est une expérience qui va vous
rendre bien vous allez toujours vient
après ça je vais vous faire une je peux
vous faire si vous voulez une bonne
famille il m'a proposé intelligent
ludique dans ces moments là tu disais
pas tu pensais pas aux gens qui
t'aimaient jacquet mais tes chansons qui
n'ont c'est ça qui est terrible parce
qu'en fait bon c'est vrai que j'avais
perdu j'aurais pensé à ça si je savais
j'aurais pas été malade simplement un
peu déprimé c'est pas du tout la même
chose
la dépression nerveuse telles que je les
ai vécu c'est pas une petite déprime
passagère et un spleen
maintenant c'est une vraie maladie grave
étudie d'ailleurs quand tu parles de ça
tu dis on projette quelque chose de
douteux et les gens le sentent et c'est
malsain ça c'est très malsain
ce qui était difficile justement c'est
de retrouver au fil des années dans le
regard des autres
normal et qui commence à te regarder
normalement qui commence à tendre à te
dire ce qu'ils pensent
parce que avant de regarder avec
méfiance aux angoisses ou avec
commisération j'étais au plus mal
commencé dans le métier ça se passe et
comment les gens ne savaient bien dans
mon métier ça se passe est pas parce que
j étais plus dans le disque est terrible
c'est qu'à ce moment là un jour tu je
pense à ça parce qu'on est sur une plage
un jour tu veux mourir ouest sur la
plage c'était le
y avait le spectacle le soir ils étaient
sept ou huit heures et j'étais avec le
gars qui conduisais ma voiture les et
d'un seul coup j'ai senti que c'était
kelvin voient en moi qui me disaient que
j'avais crevé qu'il fallait en finir ses
terres et plus aucune chance alors
j'étais sur cette plage et je regardais
une dernière fois les choses et je vais
dès ce soir de toute façon va falloir
que je me suicide
alors comment c'est ça la question alors
j'avais un hôtel évidemment d'en face et
je regardais cet hôtel j'ai quand même
pas faire ça c'est pour jean ça serait
minable
donc je cherchais un endroit pour mourir
tu parais de possession tout à l'heure
il ya et à côté possession mais c'est
pour ça je te dis que c'est lui moi
qu'il y avait quelqu'un en moi qui
m'obligeait à ça c'était très bizarre
est-ce que je passe chez catholique oui
dans ces moments là tu vas pas penser à
te retourner vers la religion terrasse
ans est allé voir un curé plutôt qu'un
psychiatre
si je les faire après après pas ce
moment là on est maintenant à ce moment
là c'était définitif le diable avait
gagné vas-y elle avait gagné façon là tu
veux tout vendre tu décides de partir tu
veux tout vent ou alors il ya je sais
pas si c'est la légende où la réalité en
face et une très belle dans tous les cas
c'est une très belle histoire le la
veille de son départ tu rencontres celle
qui est devenue la 2e femme geneviève
c'est vrai ça c'est vrai que c'était là
il a tout à fait sa place et comment
j'avais mon billet au poche et j'aurais
vendu mes meubles j'avais vendu mais
royal si à ma maison disent tout bas
mais en même temps on dit et royer oui
j'avais été vendus alors j'ai pris cet
argent qui est évidemment comme tu peux
l'imaginer j'ai vendu mes envoyais haïti
je dirais pas pour une bouchée de pain
mais passerait et puis et puis j'avais
mon billet en poche pour partir dans les
les c'était c'était c'était comme ça
quand même je lisais la vidéo garnison
fait j'aurais une chance de vivre
quelque chose ce somptueux et puis
quelques pas la veille louis la veille
c'est un peu symbolique quelques jours
avant mais j'ai rencontré dont j'ai des
amis communs et une femme qui m'a qui
m'a redonné la force parce que et de ma
elle m'a parlé de mes chansons alors
comment parler plus on a parlé de ça et
ça m'a touché la ranimer une petite
flamme la loi qui et puis elle est allée
puis elle me plaît ouais et puis ça fait
longtemps maintenant
alors après ben oui tu as commencé tu te
dis maintenant mais bon je remonte c'est
la toucher le fond de la piscine quoi tu
as donné un petit coup de pied absolu et
puis après fusil faut que je remonte à
la surface
et la suite est dit le chemin je peux
avec dur parce que je me suis pas dit
que le chemin les durs j'ai pensé qu'il
serait plus facile puisqu'il a été oui
on ne sait jamais ce qui nous attend si
on ne savait où on ferait pas la route
l'allemand était donc je pensais que
qu'il suffisait simplement les remonter
sur scène devrait enregistrer des
disques et coléreux redevenir comme
avant
ouais c'était plus long que prévu mais
ça s'est fait parce que les maisons de
disques en plus vont communier tous ces
problèmes il voulait pas trop investir
sur toi aussi
bah oui parce que tout le monde
soutienne ce qui va tenir le coin on
dirait
jamais des studios et donner à vos sims
travailler mais avec une espèce de
méfiance on
il fallait qu'à chaque fois je prouve
qu'il était possible de leur travail et
qu'ils veuillent pas mais trouvait dans
la minute qui suivait aujourd'hui alors
qu'il vit comme en plus c'est un peu
ouais c'est avec ta femme à quoi grande
borne de paris c'est-à-dire qu'ils
omettent de paris avec tes enfants les
siens en temps de les faire ensemble
donc a quand même mal an quelque chose
de solide autour de toi mais dieu merci
j'ai plus besoin de tous et de tous et
toutes choses extérieures mais qui qui
nous donne l'impression d'être d'être
bio d'être riche et en plus ça tu as
fait un truc et qui a marché là j'étais
un ange non mais et puis tu en a profité
pour faire un album alors on va en
parler de cet album
donc c'est un album qui est pas un album
de de musique brésilienne
c'est un album sur le brésil où et
comment tes commentaires entrer en
contact avec le président du népal et en
fait non plus donc oui ça s'est passé
comment ça s'est passé d'abord le l'idée
était de faire l'album brésilien parce
que je me retrouvais un peu dans cette
musique de l'album de bossa nova au
départ ça devait faire ça avec l'anah
rocky mai
car comme à dallas doit écoles primaires
s'appelle michel en fait michel et on
avait décidé tous les deux de faire un
album de bossa nova que j'avais
découvert musique de gilberto et de tous
les grands chanteurs amboise et lien que
je connaissais de façon très superficiel
mais il n'a pas approfondi et puis d'un
seul coup je me suis mis à écouter ça
change un peu et je suis tombé amoureux
de cette musique là et puis je me suis
retrouvé la danse et je me suis dit que
c'était quelque chose qui que j'avais
envie de chanter qui correspondait bien
ma sensibilité et dit moi quand j'ai vu
tous ces problèmes
quelle est la chose qui t'a réellement
aider à reprendre le dessus sur cette
période effectivement tout à fait
trouble et troublée quelle est la chose
qui t'a vraiment aidé à reprendre le
dessus
ce qui me donne le plus à reprendre le
dessus c'est pour une chose c'est une
femme
ouais c'est la mienne je crois que s'il
n'avait pas été là je pense pas que
j'aurais repris le dessus
parce que si j'avais fait ce que j'avais
dit que je ferais c'est à dire partir
dans les îles vivre je crois
qu'aujourd'hui je serai moment parce que
c'était finalement la perdition assuré
j'avais j'avais rien à y faire
donc c'est ça cc c'est l'amour de
déjà dominateur et puis et puis je crois
que c'est aussi d'avoir cru au miracle
on est donc en fait c'est la fois ouais
parce que j'ai cru au miracle
j'étais donc en sixième dessous tous les
écuries vont rire et puis je n'ai pas
j'ai pas céder à cette tentation et je
me suis dit que quelque chose arriverait
et quand on croit comme un petit bébé
que les choses vont arriver
elle arrive donc finalement c'est une
femme quitte à laisser déraillé et c'est
une femme quitta remis sur les rails
team allemand joli petit chef de gare